pour avoir refusé de coopérer dans
l'enquête parlementaire sur la saut du
Capitole du 6 janvier 2021 Steve Bannon
est donc condamné à quatre mois de
prison et 6500 dollars d'amende mais il
n'ira pas tout de suite en prison
le temps de la procédure d'appel lancé
par son avocat il pourra rester en
liberté a décidé le juge un juge qui n'a
donc pas retenu les arguments de
l'ancien proche conseiller de Donald
Trump qui disait ne pas pouvoir
témoigner devant le Congrès puisque ces
décisions avec l'ex-président était
frappé de la confidentialité du
privilège présidentiel
Donald Trump n'a pas invoqué ce droit et
Steve Bannon qui était un citoyen privé
le 6 janvier ne peut donc pas s'en
prévaloir
même chasser de la maison blanche
Banneux était resté proche du président
républicain et avait encore échangé avec
lui le 5 janvier 2021 à la veille de la
taque contre le Congrès après leur
conversation il avait même prédit un
déferlement infernal le lendemain à
Washington
fidèle à sa réputation d'agitateur en
chef il n'a pas pu s'empêcher de
déclarer ceci après le prononcé en ce
jour de sa peine de prison en novembre
dit-il sera le jour du jugement du
régime illégitime de Biden est lancé
comme en cela va finir
questionner sur la peine de l'ex
conseiller de son rival Joe Biden avait
cette courte réponse
je ne commande jamais ce qui concerne
Steve Bannen quelques heures plus tard
Donald Trump a reçu son assignation à
comparaître devant le comité de la
Chambre qui enquête sur la saute du
Capitole l'ex-président est vu comme
l'incitateur en chef des événements qui
ont conduit à la mort de plusieurs
personnes et de saccage du Congrès tout
cela pour tenter d'empêcher la
certification des résultats officiels
qui ont consacré la victoire du
président démocrate
[Applaudissements]
Donald Trump a jusqu'au 14 novembre pour
répondre à l'assignation à comparaître
et jusqu'ici il n'a pas vraiment donné
de signal dans un sens comme dans
l'autre ici Frédéric Arnold Radio-Canada
à Washington